Aaron chicken ova co-recipient with a
ram hershko and Owen rows of the 2004
prizing nobel prize in chemistry welcome
to this interview I'd like to start by
just exploring a few general themes when
I say the word mentorship what does that
conjure up for me it was very important
in particular because in my case at
least I share the prize with my own
supervisor and so it means a lot I was
lucky to have an excellent mentor and I
don't know if the word luck is proper
here because I picked him by purpose but
because I knew that one day both of us
are going to show the Nobel Prize but I
really searched around and I had the
privilege of searching around because I
was a physician already practicing
physician and I had my own career
basically paved or at least I could see
where I'm heading and but then I decided
to change direction and to go to
research I did it already in medical
school but then I went back to medicine
and I kind of flick back and forth back
and forth and I haven't made my mind yet
and then I decided nevertheless try
science and I went around and explore
the possibilities with several potential
mentors and each of them was very clear
about his ideas I mean let's do that and
that's the debt and I did that and you
know whatever is left here and Avram was
the young investigator just came back
from a postdoctoral fellowship I mean he
himself and there he started to work on
protein degradation basically just
corroborated previous findings from the
past some paradoxical findings that
protein degradation requires metabolic
energy typically it's the opposite when
you synthesize proteins you need energy
why to invest energy if you are taking
high-energy compounds and degrade them
into low energy ingredients which are
amino acids and Adam told me I don't
know what I'm going to do all I know
that I want to
identify the system that degrades
intracellular proteins I don't know how
to do it I don't know where it is I
don't know how it's going to look like
so he had some ideas and for me I said
wow that's wonderful this risky way and
I said let's take it for 23 years and
see you know if we are going to bump the
wall I'll go back to the o.r to the
operation theatre I had in my mind to be
a surgeon and if I get excited if even
if we don't get results i mean if i get
excited about it I stay and it was
wonderful labrum is an excellent
biochemist and after a short time we
realized that we have something very
unusual at hands and and then it
continued I learned a lot from him but
you know it was kind of a dialogue of an
active dialogue I thought that good
mentors I don't want to be proud or ever
need also may be good students
you